anything else Greiner appealed her
sentence in Russia she ain't never
leaving bro Ukraine gotta win that war
before she leaves yeah does anyone feel
bad for her I know there's all these
people being like Oh doesn't America
feel look good now don't you wish you
were sapped all my empathy for that [ __ ]
he's like we got people with weed
charges that's in jail here yeah that's
also bad yeah but I think what he was
saying is like it was like it basically
his point was like let's get them out
why are we putting all this money time
and focus on this woman who knowingly
took drugs into a country where she's
not supposed to none of us would take
drugs across countries but the people in
jail in America also knowingly sold
drugs when they weren't supposed to
that's not true what that's not true
wait why not that's not true no it is
true but now no it is true but now that
it's decriminalized or now that it's
legal here it still is criminalized and
illegal there I think that's the
separation but 100 and she went during a
time of increased tension so like you
got to be yeah she [ __ ] up a million
percent duh for somebody who was in jail
in a foreign country I feel bad for her
that [ __ ] sucks especially when you're
in jail for some [ __ ] son you were
Journal we're in a great gym
sir you [ __ ] people
you have three days on a yoga mat then
he had your own [ __ ] he was 90 days
[ __ ] food [ __ ] food nah I said it was
the whole country that's not the jails
Brittany greiner's in the jail you were
in then she's in a better spot than in
America but I feel like Russian prison
is probably not ideal the picture of the
jail cell if that's the one that she's
permanently in rough for a gay black
chick in Russia I feel like it's
probably not great now Russian jail is
wild B that was a bad especially for
like she's basically like a prisoner of
war at this point like yeah she's an
American gay black weed in jail bro do
you feel bad do you feel bad for her
yeah like I could imagine like because
you presented it like you don't feel bad
no I do know he presented it like he did
feel that oh really yeah oh I got the
opposite you were like does anyone feel
bad for bringing it vaccinated recently
I did you got a little teased out I got
my fifth vaccine according to the
comments on my Instagram posts
having a hard time picking up social
stuff dude that's what it is no but like
I do feel bad for it I just really
relate to Lex it's like finally watch
one last week a little emotional
intelligence this is what's up okay but
yeah I don't know I do feel bad for her
like I could I just put myself in her
situation where it's like okay I'm
bringing weed because I need it for my
whatever or I just like smoking it's a
little capsule I'm not gonna sell it
it's just for me and then you get [ __ ]
and then now you're in prison for like
the rest of your life cancer your family
friends kids whatever yeah her the
oligarch that owns her [ __ ] team will
get her out of jail if anything happened
or if they ever arrested her for any
little thing they'd be like no this is
Brittany grinder she's a superstar she
plays on my team this is my little pet
project this is kind of fun it just so
happens is during wartime like you said
she's more of a prisoner of war than she
is a prisoner but then also people don't
have any empathy for her because they're
like oh you criticized America during
all the BLM stuff she was like America's
racist she like kneeled for national
anthem whatever else two things can be
true yo America can be racist and if
you're American and you believe that we
shouldn't be like if your idea of
America is we shouldn't be we should
live up to the values of America you
should criticize the racism in America
yeah if you're proud of the racism in
America then you're like [ __ ] shut up
that's my culture but if you believe in
what the Constitution says and you
believe in the values you should support
the people who push back against the
things that don't live up to it I don't
think there's anything wrong with her
saying that reach and I love America and
I love America let's say Brittany
Greiner did some stuff to piss people
off in America it doesn't mean that she
should be a [ __ ] prison of war in
Russia yeah you know I mean now people
will go say she broke the rules she did
did yeah like and I don't know if we
would go to Thailand to take other
people that get called with drugs out
there back yeah I don't know if we do
that I know that she's a famous person
so all of a sudden we care more where
there are probably plenty of Americans
that got caught with drugs in different
countries they got arrested
I don't know what America is doing then
yeah
so it yeah this is the benefit and a
curse of of being famous yeah just
different degrees of how much you feel
bad it's like you feel bad but I don't
feel like
that isn't that crazy yeah I know it
sucks saying it but it's true yeah but
what are the other celebs doing I don't
know like what are the celebs that are
talking about doing like what do they
want done do they want preferential
treatment for the wealthy uh famous
person
is that what they're asking like I'm
like when like LeBron or these people
are tweeting about it what are they
saying this person is more important
than the people that are in jail here we
should care about her because she's
famous
I guess just because we know her
like you care about people you know I
agree with that we know her so it feels
more real it feels more no again we
don't see the other people that are kind
of like what I was saying about the
iPhones or whatever we don't see the
other people in jail for the trumped-up
charges yeah we see her in jail yeah
care about this one and I feel better
people in jail America though they sold
weed and now they're [ __ ] locked up
oh yeah let every single one of them
being in prison for like a year sucks I
was thinking about that [ __ ] dude that
is awful yeah and also like being in
prison for something that's legal that
the state is making money on yeah you
know the state is making money that's
crazy yeah and you're still locked up
yeah son fighting the bouncer bro crazy
no no no no no
damn sweet rough